au début de la pandémie plusieurs
hôpitaux ont dû s'adapter à la copie 19
l'hôpital charles lemoyne de longueuil
en est un exemple frappant
il sait transformer rapidement pour
faire face à la crise
la menace que représente le coronavirus
inquiète de plus en plus le gouvernement
on est dans une crise qui va durer des
moore au retour de la semaine de relâche
la pandémie déferle sur québec en cette
première soirée dj d'épicés douces
patients le lendemain je suis rentré en
surnuméraire pour traiter une autre
dizaine de patients le 10 mars la vague
frappe l'hôpital charles lemoyne en
montérégie
tout d'abord à l'urgence teuton a alerté
nos directions autant là il va falloir
qu'on fasse quelque chose parce que on
dit les y ait de plus en plus de quoi
qui s'en vient
[Musique]
donc il faut identifier les portes
d'entrée distingue les salles d'attentes
distinctes
et puis faire en sorte que les patients
ne se croisent pauvres c'est le début de
la transformation de l'hôpital charles
lemoyne
une semaine plus tard
l'établissement est désigné hôpital de
phase 2 il doit recevoir les 4 que 8,19
sur les principaux hôpitaux montréalais
dépassent leur pleine capacité
est-ce que ça va exploser est ce qu'on
est capable d'accommoder tous ces
patients malades le temps est compté et
la transformation est profonde la coved
19 h angers l'hôpital charles lemoyne
pour de bon voici comment
[Musique]
l'hôpital charles lemoyne et le plus
gros de la rive-sud et compte 3500
employés
il a été inauguré en 1966 tout notre
hôpital était pas du tout organiser pour
recevoir des patients avec un virus
hautement contagieux sur le plan
respiratoire
dès les premiers jours la docteur
chantal vallée a le mandat de trouver un
endroit dans l'hôpital pour recevoir les
patients atteints de l'accord et 19
l'unité de poids près à sa première
inquiétude le manque de chambres
d'isolement est essentielle pour
contenir le virus
ce sont des chambres dont la pression
atmosphérique est inférieure à celle du
reste de l'hôpital empêchant ainsi l'air
et les virus d'en sortir
on est un hôpital où on n'avait pas de
chambre après sont négatives ou presque
pas il n'y en a que 7 et elles sont
dispersées à l'urgence et sur les étages
aucune en soins intensifs
on attend possiblement des centaines de
patients pire il est difficile de créer
une zone qu'ovide au coeur de l'hôpital
le problème c'est la ventilation en fait
aux soins intensifs de tours central et
ventilés de façon homogène se dire qu'on
ne peut pas exclure la ventilation à
différents endroits et soit êtes assez
fin de partie de l'air circule au bloc
opératoire de taxes de l'air circule au
deuxième étage général d'orthopédie et
une autre partie circulent dans la
dialyse les juste en dessous en fait des
soins intenses
la solution un nouveau pavillon
récemment inauguré dédié aux
hospitalisations brève sa ventilation
est distincte du reste de l'hôpital
le rez-de-chaussée servira aux soins
intensifs le premier étage au patient
kobe de positif moins critique
on a dû recréer une unité de soins
intensifs de toutes pièces à partir de
ce qu'on avait déjà
dans la fin de semaine du 18 mars entre
on ne transforme des courts séjours en
somme toute saison nous y voici
dans la nouvelle zone qu'ovide de
l'hôpital on ne lever certaines cloisons
pour être capable d'isoler à l'intérieur
du pavillon un endroit pour le personnel
soignant par l'inventeur de ce qu'on
avait comme matériel disponible en free
2 moniteurs cardiaques
en fait deux ventilateurs en fait de 2,6
m 2 des départs et de pression
artérielle
[Musique]
le maire
le nouveau dans une idée de jean tigana
de 22
pour créer une pression d'air négative
on utilise ces ventilateurs servant
habituellement en construction pour
évacuer la poussière des chantiers a
priori on l'a retrouvé une nouvelle
vocation pour les besoins de la cause
le 22 mars ont fait appel à la docteur
nathalie morice est tout pour donner à
dax et au personnel c'est l'une des
spécialistes des cas d'orange des
situations critiques où les hôpitaux
doivent recevoir soudainement de grand
nombre de cas elle prépare les hôpitaux
à toute éventualité
le premier constat c'est que ça
prendrait quelqu'un pour s'occuper des
trajectoires et non pas que tout le
monde se met à faire des trajectoires
parce qu'il faut comprendre que
l'urgence charles lemoyne est à une
extrémité de l'édifice et que les hommes
peuvent être évitées dédié à l'autre
extrémité d'édifices pour se rendre à la
zone qu'ovide les passions rouge ceux
qui ont un diagnostic confirmé doivent
partir de l'urgence et emprunter ce
corridor qui traverse l'hôpital en
cohabitation avec les autres patients
dans ce même corridor circulent les
employés de l'hôpital qui se rende ici
aux ascenseurs ce que c'est vraiment le
coeur de l'hôpital
à voir la prandelli énormément vous
hantera cette parution
c'est ici aussi que convergent toutes
les trajectoires preuve dans l'urgence
celle des patients rouge avec un
diagnostic confirmé de qu'ovide celle
des jaunes
les patients avec des symptômes ne que
vides et les verts tout le monde en fait
rentrer en entonnoir dans le corridor
était le seul corridor qui donnait accès
à l'unité de courts séjours
autre problème majeur entre l'urgence et
la zone qu'ovide se trouve l'entrée
principale de l'hôpital en période de
pointe
500 patients passent ici à l'heure c'est
lampre commune en fait pour le centre de
cancérologie et pour l'hôpital par ici
entre donc des patients et mino
supprimer qu'il faut impérativement
protéger du virus
la première chose que note annie
morrissette fait c'est d'interdire cet
ampli aux employés à la dédie aux
ambulances amenant des patients
provenant d'autres hôpitaux avec un
diagnostic confirmé de coved 19 ce qui
réduit le nombre de patients infectés
traverse hôpital depuis l'urgence mais
nathalie morissette veut aller plus loin
elle veut séparer les différentes
populations l'hôpital les employés de
différents départements les types de
patients chacun avec des entrées et des
trajectoires distingue rapidement ça a
été de marché l'hôpital et de comprendre
des lieux physiques et en fait on a
marché l'hôpital les trois étages où les
coqs d'or au fil des années de nouvelles
annexes ont été ajoutées à l'hôpital le
centre de cancérologie la nouvelle
urgence
l'unité de course les jours il reste
alors beaucoup de portes vestiges
inutilisés en se promenant notre rue des
portes de secours dans cette borne est
capable de rire
pour être capable de diviser les gens à
l'entrée
dal créée par exemple cette trajectoire
incongru pour les pathologistes par une
porte qui mène au sous sol puis à une
cage d'escalier réservés quand vous
rappeler le matin pour prenez la porte à
droite la porte à gauche
savez vous combien de trajectoire vous
avez créé en fait de la psychiatrie et
la l'obstétrique la pédiatrie
le bloc opératoire pour les autres
cabines pour le ccm pour l'urgence pour
monde pour les patients décédés ou moins
une douzaine de trajectoire distingue
l'hôpital employait six entrées avant la
pandémie
il en possède à présent 17 des portes
qu'il faut sécuriser et garder le nombre
d'agents de sécurité passent d'une
dizaine à plus de 35 oui à fait parfait
disons le clairement nous sommes dans la
partie la plus pénible et 13 de cette
histoire ni avril
la pandémie menace d'atteindre son pic
avec plus de 35000 4 confirmés au canada
dont dix huit mille au québec au début
on isole est juste les gens qui étaient
une voyage puis après dès qu'on a eu
jusqu'à 6 ans communautaire ballon on
est isolé un petit peu plus on s'est
rapidement rendu compte
on a la saturation club il faut créer
une nouvelle unité qu'ovide au cinquième
étage cette fois avec de nouvelles
chambre à pression négative en quelques
semaines
l'hôpital charles lemoyne est passé de
cette chambre à pression négative à 21h
puis à 60 et une chambre assez pour
recevoir les patients au pire de la
crise où l'établissement héberger
jusqu'à 80 patients en même temps à
tinqueux vide
on a mis en place le mieux que ce que
l'on pouvait ya eu des nuits où je me
suis questionnée est-ce que c'était le
meilleur
la meilleure trajectoire est ce que on
devrait faire passer les ans par là
la première vague s'est apaisé les zones
coved ont été réduites au moment du
tournage en juillet elle ne comptait
plus que sept patients
mais dr morissette continue de chercher
à améliorer les trajectoires
maintenant ça va être formidable de voir
si on est capable d'avoir des chiffres
de voir c'est quoi le flot de patients
de voir si même si on crée une
trajectoire sur le rouge
est ce que les patients se mélangent
cette zone entonnoir là j'ai bien hâte
de voir combien de patients passent par
l'ofs son idée cd des nouvelles
technologies aujourd'hui débute un
projet prototype
bon on commence avec ça on verra s'il
faut remettre plus ou moins monde sait
faire en question de regarder en
fonction de l'espace elle s'allie au
docteur ado chabat urgentologue qui a
vécu l'épidémie de choléra en haïti
son entreprise développe des
technologies pour faciliter les
télécommunications en situation de
désastre humanitaire
on est convaincu qu est ce qu on a fait
comme travail actuellement va pouvoir
servir pour la deuxième vague et qu'on
va pouvoir l'améliorer
aujourd'hui on installe des récepteurs
le long des murs qui permettent de
géolocaliser en tout temps des émetteurs
ou du téléphone va partir dit hors
projet d'organiser exactement
c'est donc les données sont enregistrées
c'est ce qui permettra de suivre en
temps réel sur une application le
mouvement du personnel d'équipement
comme des civières ou même des patients
de dispositifs à terme peut être devenir
intelligent c'est à dire que peut on
peut envoyer des indications aux heures
de direct et on a vraiment dépassé la
capacité qu'on recommande maintenant
vous demande de passer par tel autre
corridor où il ya moins d'achalandage
on est capable éventuellement de
synchroniser des choses existantes
l'hôpital charles lemoyne est capable de
se transformer de jour en jour et
bientôt d'heure en heure en connaissant
bien le père et on sait ce que le bleu
la structure que nous offrir on sait par
où il faut faire rentrer les gens ça va
nous permettre de prendre de meilleures
décisions au peu importe la crise à
laquelle on va devoir faire face
on identifie trois endroits on a eu de
l'équipement supplémentaire qui vont
rester sur place parce qu'il fallait
qu'on ait des équipements distincts pour
les ondes vertes jaunes et rouges fait
que ça va rester
comme bien d'autres hôpitaux l'hôpital
charles lemoyne a été pris de court par
la pandémie
mais en ressort préparer à toute crise
future y compris à une seconde vague
[Musique]
celle devait revenir on va reconstruire
de façon progressive notre plan est bien
en place mais on sait comment faire si
tout à coup la prévalence est beaucoup
plus grande
le nombre de cas est beaucoup plus grand
et cetera qu'est ce qu'on fait on va
donner le goût puis on va se remettre en
mode en mode janko leed qui on peut le
faire en moins d'une heure
tout ce travail d'équipement rassurer
très rapidement et que certaines sont
encore certaine qu'on peut passer à
travers la pandémie la première la
deuxième vague
[Musique]